yo it's the bullet cav show special
guest
in here six tape two is out right now
two la legends bino rideau
the homie blast yes sir welcome welcome
welcome man
thank you for having us um you know
what's crazy is like i feel like since
the first six tape came out
uh so much has happened for each of you
guys
obviously bino you're on def jam now you
put out outside which is a crazy body of
work
blast you're probably the hottest
singer in the game right now man it's
crazy
i mean it's like i mean
at least from where i sit you know what
i'm saying like
um just how you guys feeling man with
all the growth since the first project
individually you know i just feel like
everything coming full
circle like it's just reinsurance that
i'm on the right path
that's how i look at everything that's
been coming my way
and um i just know i got a long way to
go so
i don't try to fall too deep in the uh
accolades that come along the way
right trying to stay focused on the end
goal
how you feeling you know um honestly i'm
feeling like it's about time
you know what i'm saying we've been just
thugging for so long holding it down and
you know what i'm saying
taking a slow route so i feel like to
finally you know what i'm saying be in
this position where we're able to
you know put our [ __ ] on display it's
it's epic you know what i'm saying
nah dude it's crazy like each of you
guys have just been
you know the last couple of years just
been on a tear like like like how do
y'all like
you know being friends be you know you
guys are going to be associated together
for the rest of your careers
um what's it like for each of you to see
each other
blow up you know what i'm saying like
what's it like to see blast become like
last you know what i'm saying like the
tour sold out in like a day i think
yeah you know what i'm saying like
what's that like and then you've just
announced the second show at the novo by
the way which is crazy you know what i
mean like how does it feel though
each of you guys would just see each
other like you know what i'm saying like
i know for me it's
it's kind of like uh you know you always
question your ear in this music [ __ ] and
for me it's just like i knew it you know
what i'm saying like back then
just tapping in with bro and you know
i'm saying that's working you know i
always knew it was something
that was that was you know saying real
real detrimental and essential for the
city you know the sound
you know i'm saying to represent the
west coast so
i always knew it was that you know i'm
saying i'm just happy to see it unfold
the show that's crazy man um blast
how you know when it came to approaching
six two or six take two um
what was like your approach from like
you know you just put out
an insane ep insane bonus edition
you're on a lot of hooks you got the
mozzie record going crazy
the jason cash record is crazy i'm sure
that there's so much stuff that we
haven't heard that's
going to be on some big projects as well
but like what what's like your approach
when it comes to approaching a
collaborative effort as opposed to like
kind of what you've been doing the last
year and some change
i mean for the main thing for me was
really just
sticking to the script and what i mean
by that is just like
knowing what got me here and um i feel
like what the people really wanted was
the 6a part 2 because that really
impacted the city
you know vino gave gave me the olyu for
people to even know who i was like i'm
always give him as much credit as i can
because who knows you know
but um i feel like my my main motive was
just making the
impact over anything just being as far
as a solo artist i'd rather
make an impact in the city yeah what
about you like you know you put out a
project outside which was crazy
uh he's on it obviously uh but did you
approach
this any differently than the first tape
or was it
kind of like picking back up where y'all
left i feel like now it was a lot more
excitement
because you know we kind of out the
pandemic and you know not necessarily
out of it but
we got a little more freedom and a
little more capability to you know what
i'm saying do what we want to do out
here do a show and
really you know touch the fans so i feel
like this time around we was juiced up
and ready to pop back outside
and uh you could hear it in the music
for sure
was it tough for each of you guys
putting out a project during the
pandemic because
i mean i know you did like a pop-up shop
and you know every
you guys did did things but like
obviously
it's not the same you know especially in
l.a [ __ ] is really
yeah shut the [ __ ] down it was at least
like like what was that was that like
how was that you know what i'm saying
did you guys feel like
you know a little disappointed with with
some of the stuff you weren't able to do
or did you feel like everything was
was you know for what it was you guys
maximize for me it was
i think a lot it was a little hesitation
you know but
overall i feel it played in my favor
because
my music is more like melodic and laid
back
stuff people can just like r b type
vibes
so i feel like people here could sit
with it more but
i wish i wish that [ __ ] really was
not going down when i dropped that
project yeah
yeah i mean you know it is what it is
man i think we finally kind of on the
other side of it
even though i feel like everybody
everybody i know has got covered in l.a
right now
it's like the [ __ ] came back in the last
like month it's crazy it's
insane man um what about on the solo tip
obviously uh
what are you working on right now
because like i said man you're on
everything right now and
i know people are wanting like a full a
full length blast album
and right now i'm just working on being
the best live performer like
i feel like that's what i've been
missing or
what i haven't been giving to people
like that that live version of blast so
the tour sold out fast exactly so i'm
trying to just perfect the show and just
rehearsing a lot yeah rehearsing trying
to work out get right get in shape
all that type of [ __ ] vocal lessons is
that the hardest part about performing
is like
getting out of breath man i don't know
what it was about the pandemic but
i'd be tired nah
for sure what about you like you know
are you are you working on your
follow-up project outside
yeah you know i'm working on a few
things i feel like mainly something that
i want to do is uh
really tap in with more you know la
artists and west coast artists in
general and
you know kind of build something that
you know we kind of are the
foundation for it seem like now and
branch off for that
i want to say when draco was here he
said you guys are working on a project
you and draco right yeah so there's
going to be a draco i mean he said this
on
on camera just so you know so it's not
like i'm playing the game
but but so there so there is a drake he
played me a couple of songs that
aren't out yet but draco and bino is on
the way huh
the thing about me and draco it's like
we spend enough time together whereas
you know if i just jump in the booth and
of course i'm here i'm perverse on this
you know i'm saying like so we got very
effortlessly too
effortless i saw that like i was you
know i always was a fan of like his
style because it's so unique
but i really when i saw him record it
really like i was like oh this dude's
like an alien
yeah he just goes in and just talks
and then hits it like i saw one take
some [ __ ] that was crazy and i was like
bruh that was like most effortless [ __ ]
i've ever seen like a rapper do like
thanks yo so is is that something that's
like official or is that something you
guys are just tossing around that you
guys haven't really decided if that's
gonna happen or not it's something we
definitely want to do
like how many records do you guys have
together that are not out
countless like we got a lot of songs i
couldn't even tell you bro
it's like we just make that much music
to it it's just like we could really
drop a couple tapes probably right now
if we wanted to
that's crazy what about you blast let me
ask you this question
who's the artist that you have the most
songs with
in the can that we don't that aren't out
i would probably say
that isn't bino it would have to be
mozzie i got a bunch of joints on mozzie
yeah you and mozzie loki is like jay-z
and r kelly before
before she got weird not for real like
you guys have
[ __ ] records man and that's another
project i think of fans would love is a
mozzie blast project that would be crazy
yeah i'll be seeing that a lot on
twitter like mazzie and blast project
would be crazy but
shout out mozzie for sure what is it
about uh mazza you think that you guys
have such a great chemistry
um i just feel like i'm able to
to step into his world and really like
speak on it from like a narrator
perspective and it's mostly just hooks
when i collab with them anyway so
i just feel like i'm able to speak on
that topic and just
give it an overall summary that's that's
kind of how i look at it
in the hook form but um yeah the
chemistry is there for sure
what was it like um you know rocking
with russ
because i feel like a lot of people kind
of compare you to russ in terms of like
what you guys bring to the table as an
artist
you know what i mean like you're like a
one-man show you can record yourself and
make the beat and
do everything right uh and he's the same
way and uh you guys put out a crazy
record you know what i'm saying
i'm sure that there's more where that
came from yeah i mean we only did two
records
i don't think the other one gonna come
out maybe it's going to be one of these
random songs he drops because he puts a
song
yeah he'll be dropping a record every
week his work ethic is crazy
but yeah shout out russ i for show
mira a lot of stuff he he do follow a
couple of um
you know [ __ ] from his blueprint did you
um
you know a lot of people kind of
question like
when you did the red bull thing
initially like wait this is crazy
like you could sign with anybody right
which is true at the time you probably
couldn't sign with anybody right
um but it's worked out like amazingly
you know what i'm saying is
is that a relationship we're gonna
continue with the next project
yeah we talking about that right now um
right now
my deal is you know damn near done but
i definitely the relationship there is
solid so i really don't see myself going
nowhere else
but um and the resources are like
limitless yeah the resources
yeah you get free red bull from this guy
yeah it's crazy because a lot of people
like i think
you know in la the the scene is this is
probably the best that it's been
in a very long time man as far as
camaraderie is concerned
um you know i was talking to like jason
cash and a few other guys just about
like
you know everybody in la it seems like
they [ __ ] with each other
you know and there's obviously politics
that come with a lot of [ __ ] you know
what i mean but for the most part
i feel like um you'll see ruchi getting
on songs with
kailyn and you'll see you guys doing a
project together and
you're talking about doing a whole joint
with draco like why do you think like
now the scene in la
seems so united as we're in the past it
felt very divided
i feel like we seen it work
you know in other places you know i'm
saying we kind of see how
they do things and we talk about you
know i'm saying states that have been on
top for years now
you know what i'm saying and we kind of
realizing that
we stronger together so
i feel like that's that's really the
spark of a lot of collaborations right
now in the west
like atlanta like atlanta's had it for
how long
they moved together so i'm crazy what do
you think blasto
yeah i mean i i just feel like it's it's
that young [ __ ] energy
like we we see what he said like
young doug like he moved like a boss
like we feel like bosses now so
we gonna run this [ __ ] how we want to
run it and shout out to the ogs that
paved the way but you know we got to
carry the torch
for the next generation so we see what
they did wrong and right
and now we can add our sauce to it you
talk about being a boss
um obviously you got eagle uh is that
like
are both of you guys looking to sign
artists or have you signed any artist or
is that something that's even
true you know you guys are still
quote-unquote new artists
but you know you came up under nipsey
who you know
obviously laid the blueprint for a lot
of [ __ ] that a lot of rappers are doing
nowadays is that something you guys are
interested in getting into
most definitely um i'm actually working
with an artist right now but
we just it's in the works right now i
don't i want to roll it out the right
way for sure but
shout out jay million for sure oh fire
what is
what do you look for like in an artist
like if you
if you make that decision to put your
stamp on artists like what is the
what are the qualities man my main thing
is just
not having to tell somebody what to do
you know so that
that natural work ethic and just
consistency
and of course talent of course but just
not having a
look at it yeah babysit exactly and i
feel like that's that's what i want him
around me man yeah it's tough because
you know you have an artist that has all
the talent in the world
yeah but unless they're told what to do
they're just gonna sit at home and play
nba 2k call of duty or some [ __ ] you
know what yeah
yeah shout out to artists again what are
we saying j j million j million
okay from out here yeah that's crazy how
excited are you you know you got two
shows at the novo first of all sold out
quick
um are you gonna be doing any tour [ __ ]
because you know his tours i
got announced are you gonna be doing a
beano tour yeah i feel like it's only
right
to kind of follow up with a tour you
know i'm saying i ain't
you know i don't want to say too much
about it but coming to the city near you
for sure
and how excited are you to finally do
like because you've been doing some club
[ __ ]
yeah you've been doing like some radio
[ __ ]
but this is like your [ __ ] nah yeah it's
fire especially
like when they know your words it's a
different type of feeling so
i can't wait to see that they know my
words in new york like because i
definitely wasn't expecting that
and i feel like that energy gave you the
motivation to go back and make some
crazier [ __ ] so
they always say uh well you say you
never heard a a
whack blast song in your opinion what's
your worst song though
that's out that's out what is your worst
song like what's your least favorite
blast song
i couldn't even tell you it'll happen
because they're all fight it'll have to
be like the first song i ever put out
and we're not gonna speak on that he's
like i don't need people looking that
[ __ ] up on youtube
now if you know you know you it's still
up too i don't know how to get
access to that youtube account but that
[ __ ] is up there
it's still up like under your name too
i don't know we should find it you gonna
have to do it can we can we pull this
out
absolutely no no no what about you like
like like like you know just talk about
growth you know because i feel like
you've come a long way just as an artist
in the last like three or four years
like you feel like you're finally
hitting your stride for sure i feel like
you know what i'm saying that's the
start of something great i feel like
you know i spent years you know i'm
saying
underneath and just you know following
that energy and picking up you know what
i'm saying
after growing to be here now and see us
doing it and see you know a lot of the
similar
similar situations i've seen bro and
it's like it's crazy and you know i just
want to
run this [ __ ] the right way and come
correct what situations you know
that that you saw him go through that
you've kind of gone through yourself now
i just mean
you know what i'm saying all the lights
just having to
do [ __ ] like this come here and talk to
you you know what i'm saying like
me being able to control my narrative
and and really
put it out there you know i'm saying
what i want to represent and
how i'm coming it's it's a lot of
pressure you know i'm saying we hold a
lot of weight on our shoulders but
it's the beauty of it i feel like yo
it's crazy because if you think about
nip and like the people who he kind of
helped bring along
like yourself j stone roddy rich with
somebody who
nip really you know that's the first
time i met rodney was witness you know
what i'm saying
it's crazy how like even through his
death like
the if you look at la's hip-hop scene
he's still living you know what i'm
saying like
it's it's crazy and shout out to dj dj
vip too who's nips dj who's now your
official dj too
shout out is he taking you snowboarding
yet no he always telling me come out
there
but that boy loved that snowboarding man
i just told him when he came i said yo
what do you do during the summer there's
no snow
what do you do in your free time it's
like i bought dirt bikes i'm like yeah
that sounds about right
ace game [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] hey
interrupting the interview
to tell you about our good friends at
odd socks now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
oh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks
underwear the boxer briefs are the best
underwear that you could ever fit on
your ass trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssoxoficial.com use
the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kevin checkout save 20
it's crazy because blast you a lot of
people look at you as a new artist
but you know i was like talking with
jason cash and he was telling me that
you guys like i think the first time you
guys ever hung out and did music
together was like
oh 8 or 09 or some [ __ ] yeah it was a
minute ago because i know him through my
my younger cousins in carson like i used
to go out there
today crib and um they went to high
school with jason cash so i've been
knowing him for a minute now
yeah no it's crazy because like the
person like like the persistence
the dedication it takes to like do music
for that long
and like barely get pop like get popping
a
decade into this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying is like was there every point in
time where you were like uh
on the fence about doing this [ __ ]
because you know at the end of the day
you got to pay your bills you got to
have
you got to put a roof over your head and
this music [ __ ] until it's it it ain't
it you know what i mean
in the back of my head i felt like i
always knew it was possible
but when i had my son i knew i had to
turn it up like
i had to think of different ways how can
i monetize it now and
because at first it was just the love of
it you know like i just enjoyed creating
[ __ ] but
now i have to uh like visualize how can
i make it an
actual business and make it bigger than
just me something i could pass down to
my son
and um yeah that moment what was like in
your opinion like a
a moment for you that kind of changed
everything i feel like to get right
would it be was
was a a you know i think that that was
probably the
first yeah that was for sure like one of
the first
moments that people start paying
attention to my name as far as a
producer in the city
cause like well how did you guys meet
cause you guys obviously didn't come up
together so how did you guys initially
meet i heard that song
and i'm like i asked kaitlyn i'm like
bro who made this
he put me on so i'm like link me you
need some more of this
and then you was like oh you could sing
yeah he just sent the song you didn't
even tell me like yeah bro i sing too he
just sent the song with some vocals on
it
turned out to be savage crazy
was that hard for you to like cause you
know when you're a producer
you don't want to be like i'm the
producer who makes music because an
artist might look at you kind of crazy
if you're whacked you know what i'm
saying uh
coming into the game is like a producer
you know was that something where it was
like you were kind of picking and
choosing like who you let
hear your [ __ ] it's kind of funny though
cuz i don't i don't really look at
myself
oh no it's weird i don't know how other
people look at me but i look at myself
like an artist that produces
like kind of like a j cole right right
he not heavily known for producing but
he got them accolades under his belt you
know and that's kind of how i want to
move
like if you know you know are you still
making beats for other people
like not that [ __ ] that you're not even
on are you still like sending packs out
yeah yeah
any any uh stuff that you know might be
coming or anything yeah i got some crazy
[ __ ] in the works for sure
can you give us a little not at all i
don't know
has there been a blast have you done a
hook recently that you were like a
little nervous because of who it was for
yeah i feel i'm i feel
i'm my biggest critic bro anything i
sent to anybody i'm always second
guessing myself
but um i like it that way because i'm
never perfect but i'm always striving
for perfection
you know but um yeah it's always like
that i'm always like damn if they gonna
[ __ ] with it or they're not gonna [ __ ]
with it
who can you let us know not who you've
worked with but like who's reached out
to you
that has let you know that they're a fan
of what you do this is for both of y'all
too
that kind of was like a big deal to you
you know what i'm saying like
a few people a few people off the top of
my head
the latest one i could think of is like
rick ross
him tapping in just being in the same
room with him
i ain't even know he was you know that
he was like up on your [ __ ]
yeah so that was a shocker for sure
what has i mean drake lives in la has
drake tapped in
no drake ain't tapped in that's gotta
that's gotta be inevitable
he lives here
i don't know what about you who's
somebody
who who's just reached out to you like
just as like a fan that you were like oh
this [ __ ] crazy
um
i probably say the craziest for me he
didn't exactly reach out
he was just kind of sliding to my [ __ ]
it was brian
lebron james yeah oh [ __ ] he was sliding
to me and j stone [ __ ] shout out j stone
but you feel me when he in the back of
that whip and he and he's
listening to your [ __ ] that's tough it's
like
lebron john loki like a and laura
lebron is definitely a r and he'd be
listening to the most
wide he'll be listening to l.a [ __ ] then
he'd be listening to like
freddie gibbs or griselda for the show
like he's super
i mean he's supposed to do an album
that's what they're saying he's going to
do like a dj khaled style
project where he just a r gotta be fire
i ain't gonna lie
cause i feel like he got the ear for it
for sure platinum did y'all see space
jam too
yeah i just seen that [ __ ] i ain't seen
it [ __ ] don't tell me what you think
i liked it i thought it was entertaining
which is kind of what it was supposed to
be right yeah like if you're going into
space jam 2 thinking it's going to be
like an academy award winning
[ __ ] movie like you're like yo this
is this is not
it's just an entertaining movie for
children in lebron james
just threw that [ __ ] on um
is there any sort of like timeline for
you guys when it comes to
the follow-up for this because i know
each we're waiting for i said we're
waiting for your full-time
full full-length album we're waiting on
a new project from you
do you think we're gonna get both of
those before the end of the year
i'm not sure i couldn't i couldn't even
tell you that especially with me about
to go on tour
it's a bunch of shows i'm finna do i'm
always creating but
to put out a body of work especially at
this moment
is is very pivotal like you gotta beat
it because everyone's watching
yeah like this is the moment where you
gotta really
lock in yeah so i'm gonna take my time
with it it's kind of like your your
kendrick moment like kendrick got the
cosign
section 80 came out it was cool but we
were all waiting to see what mad city
sounded like
oh me you know dre dre co-signed him on
the radio
game pastor latoya i feel like that's
where that's your position right now
that's tough yeah are you are you
finding yourself experimenting with it
any like different sonics like on the
new [ __ ] yeah for sure
and mainly because i feel like people
kind of predict what i'm gonna do or how
i'm gonna come
so this the new [ __ ] i've been doing
like it's not too far away of course
i'ma
stick to my what i know but i've been
leveling up for sure have you been
seeking any outside production at all
are you just keeping it all
yeah i had locked in with mike and keys
recently
just to get a different feel and also uh
the artist that i told you about jay
million he produces well
and he played a bunch of instruments so
that's just been
you know leveling up the whole sound
what about your album
before the end of the possibly
you know what i'm saying i feel like the
goal after this
is to you know obviously keep it going
you know
with class and you know what i'm saying
respectfully
however that however that is you know
what i'm saying i don't know if it's
gonna
be the album or a mixtape or what you
know what i'm saying but
we're gonna keep a new one for sure um
you you obviously learning so much from
nit man is there anything like on the
entrepreneurial side you're getting
involved in because you know he's
kind of laid the blueprint for a lot of
the this generation you know what i'm
saying
what to do when it comes to just you
know
having a a bunch of eggs in different
baskets
besides the music [ __ ] for sure yeah i i
i say
the biggest thing you know i'm saying
that i want to
continue you know what i'm saying per se
from nip is just the community you know
i'm saying like different outlets
outside of music you know i'm saying
just to
promote growth and wellness
just within ourselves bro just all
generations i feel like
it's necessary for someone you know i'm
saying able
to step in and kind of play that role
fire
uh blast you're on a lot of big
festivals coming up
in vegas you want to roll them loud
right yeah i am in love miami
i heard you guys have a party friday is
this true yeah we throwing a day party
in miami
all right i gotta fall through this i'm
gonna be out there um
but uh are you what what because you're
on some pretty crazy lineups
fast pretty wild lineups what which
lineup did you see
that you were like oh i need to watch
this [ __ ] like because you're on some
pretty crazy
what lineup that i see that that i'm on
yeah that you're on where you're like
man
we might need to just go be on some fan
[ __ ] for this
um i would say that her festival
um coming up it's going to be in oakland
turn the lights on festival but
it's hosted by erica badu in herself
soon as i see erica but i do i'm like
yeah i got to come in some [ __ ] i ain't
coming regular i got to have a live band
background
singers background dancers yeah you know
you know that festival everyone's gonna
have the live band
yeah yeah for sure erica that was crazy
live too
i'm already knowing in her she crazy
live i've seen her early on at the
observatory
i'm a big fan of her let me ask you for
la like why did you decide to do
the roxy well you're doing it multiple
times right
yeah you probably could have did like
the novo like him or
i don't know i just wanted to keep it
humble i really didn't have no
expectations
until after we saw it i mean
i really didn't have no expectations
period but um
for the most part like as far as the
agency it was just the dates didn't
align with the tour so
roxy was the perfect fit to keep the
tour in the same route
how many days are you doing at the roxy
no two days two
you could probably do like eight crazy
i'm being serious there's like 500
people there right
it's like small in there yeah it's it's
hot as [ __ ] at the roxy i mean you've
been there
you know that's it look man look the
project is out
great timing for the summertime um
great body of work i think it's uh is
that which which song are you guys
noticing as like the one that's like
getting the tick tocks moving or
getting like getting some love in the
club is there like one record that's
kind of standing out right now
on on six tape too or is it just the
whole project's getting love
that [ __ ] is going i ain't gonna lie
i'm just hearing the same thing from
everybody you know i'm saying you gotta
let it play
front to back no skips no skips man
skips yeah
look the album is out go get it we'll
mix tape whatever we're calling it
hopefully you and drake will put a
project out okay that incredible record
go crazy
i look forward to that you said you were
tapping with a bunch of la artists who
else in la do you have a bunch of [ __ ]
with
i wouldn't say a bunch of [ __ ] but i'll
say some names y'all need to get
familiar with
airplane james sham going crazy
uh shout out asia the list goes on blue
bush clan you know what i'm saying it's
a bunch of
bunch of dope la artists everybody needs
to tap in with shuffle show
yeah um i felt like
it would have been criminal had you have
not made the
freshman cover
talk about the freshman thing i don't
feel like that i felt like it was early
honestly but um like i said before like
the music speaks
you know and that's just what i live by
but i really felt like
it was too early for me to be you think
so yeah
maybe like next year some after the next
project
but staff like they showed dumb love
when i met with them
and they was a fan of the music over
everything and i appreciate that
they still hold that integrity there
like they get a lot of
flack but it's a couple of artists on
there that i was like damn they
they really tapped in so i appreciate
that yeah now i feel like uh
the double xl always gets the east coast
bias
yeah when it comes to like when we have
every time we see the cover
like but you know i feel like
it's with all the noise coming out of la
it feels like it's finally
ever like you said you're about to go
see a bunch of kids in new york sing
along to your [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
roddy had one of the biggest albums ever
and i mean i feel like shit's finally
starting to kind of come this way man
again so it's a good look well like i
appreciate y'all